Ethan this mission of yours
heard that Tom Cruise does his own
stunts it may have seemed like an
impossible mission back in 1996 to
revive an old TV show and turn it into a
mega successful two decade spanning film
franchise but that's exactly what
happened and before the upcoming seventh
installment it's theaters let's go on a
quick mission that is very possible as
we tell you everything you need to know
before you go see Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part one your life will
always matter more to me than my own
let's take a deep breath like we just
narrowly escaped death for the umpteenth
time and get on with it let's go back to
the film that started it all Mission
Impossible kicking it all off was one of
two big films for Tom Cruise in 1996.
with the other being Jerry Maguire so in
other words I think it's safe to say
that you're really showed him the money
anyway Mission Impossible is a
continuation of both the original
television series created in 1966 and
the revived sequel series which began in
1988. loving the double numbers there
with the movie Set six years after the
events of the latter Tom SARS is a
government operative Ethan Hunt who
recruits a small team to help improve
his innocence after he becomes a prime
suspect in the murder of his mentor of
course this movie delivered one of the
most memorable scenes slash images of
90s action flicks I'm sure you all
remember where you were when Ethan drops
and hovers inches from the ground as it
turns out Tommy put coins in his shoes
for balance and to keep his head from
hitting the floor which is a great life
hack if you plan to be a future spy and
fun fact this is actually the only film
in the franchise where Ethan Hunt
doesn't fire a gun nor are there any
shootouts or gunfights at all yes more
of that please up next is
Mission Impossible too sorry I can't
help myself greatest theme song ever now
this installment May hold the lowest
score on the Tomato Meter as the only
rotten movie of the bunch but I will say
it was the highest grossing movie of the
year 2000 and as our friends in Wu Tang
say cash rules everything around me
sorry I'm in a singing mode right now
now in this one Ethan and team joins
forces with a professional Thief played
by Thandie Newton as they try to track
down a genetically modified disease
being held by a rogue agent and while
Sir Anthony Hopkins making an uncredited
Cameo appearance may ring a bell from
number two it's really Tom Cruise's
entrance scene that is this one's major
calling card it features him free solo
climbing at dead horse Point State Park
in Utah TomTom was wearing a harness
with a thin wire and there was no safety
net so I guess it's pretty impressive
moving on to Mission Impossible 3.
number three in the Mi film series was
directed by JJ Abrams in his directorial
debut and yes lots of lens flares Tom
Cruise called and offered JJ the job
after Tom binge the first two seasons of
Abrams his popular show aliased note to
self pick up unknown calls now in this
film Ethan Hunt is retired from active
duty and training new recruits but he's
forced to go up against a ruthless arms
dealer played by Philip Seymour Hoffman
who is threatening hunt and those that
he loves and speaking of Hoffman Mission
Impossible 3 is one of the strongest
overall casts that we've seen in the
franchise with names like Michelle
Monaghan Billy crude up Jonathan Rhys
Meyers Carrie Russell Maggie Q and
Lawrence Fishburne joining in on the fun
now unlike number two this one performed
worse at the box office but better with
critics geez I guess you could stay
pleasing people is an impossible mission
either way the mission was already being
set for number four onward to Ghost
Protocol which finds Ethan Hunt's
employers The Impossible missions Force
shut down after being publicly
implicated in a bombing of the Kremlin
so Ethan and his team have to go without
resources or backup to try and clear
their names this movie the first of what
has been three straight certified fresh
installments includes Paula Patton and
in a supporting role it also includes
the first involvement of Christopher
McCrory who did an uncredited rewrite of
the script and would go on to direct at
least four movies in this series but
let's be honest at this point we pretty
much associate Mission Impossible movies
with crazy Tom Cruise stunts and for
this one it was him climbing up the side
of the tallest building in the world no
big deal you gotta be kidding me okay my
friends numero Cinco Mission Impossible
Rogue Nation this time Ethan Hunt and
his team are on the run from the CIA and
find themselves in a war against an
international Black Ops terrorist
organization composed of Rogue Agents
from all over the world the film was
written and directed by Christopher
McCrory his first of at least four
mission impossible films he had
previously directed Cruz in Jack return
2012 and get this he also wrote and
produced top gun Maverick in 2022. I
mean talk about a power couple tying
this one to a crazy stunt for your
memory banks would have to be Tom Cruise
performing death-defying Maneuvers with
a real flying Airbus us at 5000 feet in
the air I mean what okay now that we've
survived all of those let's talk about
the Henry Cavill One 2018's mission
impossible Fallout is a certified fresh
97 on the Tomato Meter making it the
highest rated film in the franchise at
the time of this recording this time
Ethan and his team joined forces with
CIA assassin August Walker to try and
prevent an epic disaster unfortunately
August played by the Henry Cavill isn't
who he really appears to be and that
leads to one hell of a climactic chopper
Chase between the two stars this
sequence took six weeks to shoot and it
happened over mountainous terrain on the
south island of New Zealand one of The
film's Producers said it took two years
to plan and claims that it was even more
extreme than Crews hanging onto the side
of the flying plane in Rogue Nation you
gotta think to yourself how are they
going to one-up themselves for number
seven can't wait to find out oh wait I'm
the one telling you okay here we go so
this of course leads us to the seventh
mission in the Mission Impossible film
series dead reckoning part one well what
exactly is a dead reckoning well based
on what we know it's Ethan Hunt's most
dangerous Mission yet and that I gotta
say is seriously saying something I mean
have you been paying attention the last
couple minutes more specifically it
means that agent Han and friends will
have to track down a very dangerous
weapon that threatens Humanity before
the bad guys get it so I guess this is
their most dangerous Mission yet and it
kind of sounds like a Fast and Furious
movie
on top of that we know that some
so-called Dark Forces from Ethan's past
will also be involved making his life
even more difficult and requiring even
more crazy stunts in fact you'll be
excited to hear that this Mission
Impossible film has one of the most
aggressive stunts in cinematic history
Tom does a motorcycle Cliff jump into a
base jump in Norway and in order to pull
this off T-man went through a year of
advanced skydiving training base
training control canopy training and
Motocross training just to pull this off
pretty much the biggest stunt in cinema
history
Tom Cruise just rode a motorcycle off a
cliff six times today and of course in
typical Tom and Christopher McCrory
fashion they love to take audiences
along for the ride and Christopher
actually admitted that the camera they
needed to shoot this thing didn't even
exist until a couple years ago needless
to say it sounds like they truly did one
up themselves so much so that McCrory
said the only thing that scared him more
about this stunt is is what they have
planned for Mission eight fresh and
familiar faces when it comes to who will
be playing out the story on the big
screen joining Tommy as returning stars
are Ving Rhames Simon Pegg and Rebecca
Ferguson now when it comes to new faces
joining The Fray we're gonna meet Haley
atwell's Grace character whom Atwell
described as having quote somewhat
ambiguous loyalties which come on that
sounds pretty interesting we're also
going to meet a powerful terrorist and
the film's main villain Gabriel played
by esai Morales who was cast after
Nicholas Holt left due to scheduling
conflicts we're also going to see
Vanessa Kirby as a black market arms
dealer known as white widow and the
always awesome Shea Wiggum as an
enforcer who's tracking Ethan don't mess
with Eli from Boardwalk Empire so what
about dead reckoning part two well
friends based on the film's title you've
probably figured out by now that there
will be more dead reckonings to come now
while we know that part 1 will end in a
cliffhanger probably I mean literally we
can't tell you much of what's gonna
happen in part two but we do know that
it has already been filmed filmed and is
due out around the same time next year
Tom Cruise is officially The Unofficial
King of the summer box office and just
to give you the time to properly grieve
it has been reported that these two dead
reckonings will serve sadly as a
send-off for Ethan Hunt I mean what come
on Tom take a cue from The Fast and
Furious franchise and let's just keep
this thing going anyways friends that's
everything you need to know before you
go see Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part 1 in theaters July 12th and I think
this goes without saying but definitely
check it out in IMAX if you can my name
is Naz Perez thanks for watching and be
sure to rate and review this film at
rottentomatoes.com
[Music]
foreign